we start with breaking news and boris
johnson has just announced that he's
stepping up preparations for
a no deal brexit as hopes of a trade
agreement with the eu
fade negotiations are ongoing in
brussels to try to break the deadlock
but the prime minister says there's now
a strong possibility that it won't
happen
i've just uh updated cabinet on where
we've got to with our
friends and partners in the eu and
they agreed very strongly with me that
the deal on the table
is really not at the moment right for
the
for the uk and i'll tell you why there's
a couple of uh of things
at least the the most important is that
really just in the last couple of weeks
they've brought
back the idea of this equivalence
between the
the uk and the and the eu which
basically means that
whatever new laws they brought in we
would have to
to follow or else face punishment
sanctions
uh tariffs or whatever and it was put to
me that this was kind of a bit like
twins and uh the uk's one twin the eu's
another
and if the eu decides to have a haircut
then the uk
has got to have a haircut or else face
punishment or the eu decides to buy an
expensive handbag
the uh the eu decides to find an
expensive handbag then the uk
has to buy an expensive handbag too or
else face
uh terrorists and punishment and clearly
that's not a sensible
way to proceed it's unlike any other uh
free trade
deal uh it's a way of keeping the the uk
kind of in the locked in the the eu's
orbit in their regulatory orbit and
the second thing obviously is the is
fisheries where many years now after
people have voted to
to leave the the eu we wouldn't still
have control of our of our waters and
that's no good and so they can agree
very strongly that
uh we're really not there yet
at all and what i've said to our
negotiators
is that we've got to keep going and
we'll go the extra mile
and we will and i will go to brussels
i'll go to paris
i'll go to berlin or wherever to try to
to get this home and get to a deal
but there's always the possibility the
prospect
of coming out on australian terms which
i believe
are very good terms and we as i say can
prosper mightily
in that future uh which is just around
the corner
and there are all sorts of amazing
opportunities for this country
and so what i told the the cabinet uh
the see this evening is to is to get on
and make those and make those
preparations we're not stopping
the talks we'll continue uh to negotiate
but looking at where we are
i do think it's vital that everybody
now gets ready for that australian
option